c'était les dernières élections de cette
année 2010 est 170 sénateurs ont été
élus ce dimanche 24 septembre dans les
yvelines six sièges ont été pourvus
le détail de ses résultats dans le
département avec nicolas landry de la
rédaction tv 78 bonsoir bonsoir grille
alors qu'elles ont saignements tirer de
ces élections sénatoriales dans le
département
alors je vous propose de voir les
nouveaux sénateur des yvelines et c'est
quasiment un grand chelem pour les
républicains
la liste de gérard larcher a obtenu cinq
sièges sur les six renouvelables une
victoire logique au vu de la composition
du corps électoral
le président du sénat a été réélu tout
comme sophie primas un résultat salué
notamment par la présidente de la région
ile de france valérie pécresse sur son
compte twitter comme vous le voyez à
l'image de son côté la république en
main je décroche le dernier siège avec
l'élection de martin le vrillé à ce
propos écouter aurore bergé porte parole
du groupe la république en marche à
l'assemblée nationale elle était au
micro de mélanie poquet ce qui n'était
pas évident c'est que nous réussissent à
avoir des élus aux sénatoriales
parce que la république en marche vous
le savez bien n'existait pas au monde et
municipales en 2014 n'existait pas au
moment des départementales ou des
régionales
donc on a eu quand même des grands
électeurs des élus venant de la gauche
venant de la droite ou sans étiquette
qui ont fait le choix de la république
en marge nicolas vous avez parlé de la
droite du parti présidentiel également
la république en marche
tel est le résultat de la gauche pour ce
scrutin alors rappelez vous grégory la
gauche yvelinoise détenait deux sièges
au sénat avant ce scrutin
elle n'a pas réussi à les conserver
faute sans doute à la multiplication des
candidatures à gauche le parti
socialiste arrive néanmoins en troisième
position mais elle n'a pas obtenu assez
de voix pour obtenir un siège
je vous propose d'écouter la sénatrice
sortante socialiste catherine tasca
c'est certain que la multiplication des
listes c'est vrai d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup de départements a été mortel il
ya notamment à gauche réflexe serait
suicidaire puisque toutes les formations
concernées se sont trouvés dans
l'incapacité de négocier des accords
saad et moi en 2011
j'ai fait ma liste avec l'ensemble des
formations de gauche et le résultat
était là parmi les nouveaux sénateurs on
retrouve également michel laugier
effectivement le président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines a été élu sénateur dans la
liste les républicains et il a déjà une
idée sur la manière dont il va exercer
son nouveau mandat
écoutez le moi je compte ne pas changer
je suis représentant des élus locaux et
bois bon c'est cette expérience là que
j'ai pu avoir à travers mes différentes
fonctions qui va me permettre de pouvoir
voter de les lois les améliorer et faire
avancer notre pays
du coup nicolas c'est automatique avec
la loi sur le non-cumul des mandats qui
est entrée en vigueur le 1er juillet
dernier michel auger va devoir quitter
ses fonctions de maire de montigny le
bretonneux également président de
l'agglomération alors pas d'automatisme
et puisque la loi stipule que michel
laugier dispose de 30 jours pour
notifier sa démission au préfet se
posera alors la question de la
succession de michel laugier à montigny
le bretonneux et à la tête de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
dans l'après-midi des voix se font déjà
entendre le conseiller communautaire
othman nasro appel je le cite à
l'organisation d'une primaire interne au
sein de la majorité afin de fixer les
orientations de la seconde moitié du
mandat communautaire fin de citation
mais il ya déjà des noms qui circulent
notamment pour la présidence celui du
maire d'elancourt jean michel fourgous
ou celui de la mère de plaisir joséphine
coleman ce berger merci nicolas et pour
être complet sur ce sujet un conseil
municipal doit se tenir dans la soirée à
montigny le bretonneux et un conseil à
d'agglomération aura lieu ce jeudi 28
septembre transports